why it's weird is because everyone here
is picturing the sun cream pieing the
[ __ ] out of the mall
I'm just thinking about a oh I wasn't
picturing it
[Music]
I'ma show you guys a family photo and
you just try to tell me what you think
is going on here
oh what the [ __ ]
all right why is he doing the Biden
smell
the butters yeah you know the Biden
all right that's that looks like no that
looks like uh wait wait wait who is that
that's the Sun that looks like the sun
for sure that's that looks like Pops
Pops and it looks like Mom because if
that was like the wife that's weird to
me oh I think I think it's a a stepdad
and the stepdad son they're sharing a
wife but then but she's pregnant with
the stepsons baby it's hard to tell they
all right that's good you noticed that
you notice the pregnancy okay let's see
where the hands are that's trying to
they're trying to show us something okay
that's you first I thought it was them
they're a couple and then the dad was
glad because he's the dad but then now
I'm like oh she's actually his age okay
here's here's another hit she looks old
though that's I didn't see that in the
beginning that's dad and mom see okay
that is the son of these two okay whose
is that the son's child the son's child
in vitro style surrogates uh the mom's a
suriga mom you have a very sad life are
very non-perverse that's a a grandson
and brother
combo kids at the sun brother and
Grandson their last name is Targaryen no
you're right so what happened is this
son and his wife she had like to get a
emergency hysterectomy a long time ago
so she can't have kids what's a
hysterectomy it's where you uh get rid
of the reproductive so and so of the of
the feet
so did they save is the female version
of a vasectomy yeah do they save her
eggs or something and then yeah yeah so
what they they already him and his wife
already have two sets of twins they're
in vitro whoa and they wanted a fifth
child yeah and of course like when you
have a when you do in vitro you need to
get another carrier sometimes the mom
offered to be the carrier for her son's
baby so in vitro's not like IVF is it
something else because isn't it
dangerous to have women over a certain
name it is
is IVF yeah oh it is oh in vitro
fertilization IBM okay she's 56. but the
doctor cleared her to be able to be
pregnant really so she ended up being
the person to care maybe she's healthy
as [ __ ] yeah she might be 56 dude I mean
she looks pretty good for 56. I think
it's Unique and slightly weird because
it's unusual but I feel like there's a
very strong practicality to it as well
and it's not that different because
they're white right yeah you know like
this already kind of
yeah
I think my question is like if if you
like modern flying why would you fly a
plane with propellers on it
what it's like there's a lot of people
that have a modern you know tum tums why
you gotta find a [ __ ] prehistoric
tomtoms to put your baby it could be
cops that's what I'm saying there's
there's got to be like other weird
variables that kind of make it logical
because then uh let's say you have to go
find a surrogate to like host your baby
yeah and then you gotta like also
interview them make sure they're the
right person you don't really know
anything about them so I can understand
how a
take the fact that you know there's this
mom concept that's in play but just like
a as a mother figure you trust them you
know that they're capable have done this
before she's gonna look out for her son
yeah she's gonna give you a discount at
her grandson yeah I guess so that's you
know why it's weird is because everyone
here is picturing the sun cream pieing
the [ __ ] out of the mall
I'm just thinking about a oh I wasn't
picturing it an hour for sure
I know you guys were thinking Joe's like
I know it's weird because everybody has
a 4K version of porno nasty ass Chris
was picturing that [ __ ] I was just
thinking about an old lady man but now
does it count she looks like sis though
whoa that's crazy wait does it does it
count as his brother now because it's
his mom that's giving birth well that's
the thing though because it's her egg
it's the wife's egg the mom is literally
just a surrogate boss you're just
holding it it's a plastic bag just a
womb yeah yeah in this sense but a
trusted womb that has like the familial
Bond like such a care for the child even
in like as she's growing this thing in
her body it's not like in nine months
I'm gonna get 35 Grand it's like in nine
months I'm I'm still gonna care for you
so that that love and that energy is
also a part of the problem yeah you're
right and is it probably going to be a
C-section at that age probably it
probably is
see I'll tell you what if I'm the sun
I'm not going to be in the pregnancy
room looking at a Nazi section you know
what I'm saying that's a good point get
your mom give birth yeah I'm not I'm not
trying to be there even though I didn't
even think about that man I'm gonna
smoke a cigar in the [ __ ] other room
the funny thing I mean they could both
be there watching the birth happen I
think
[Music]
I don't get your child yeah the magic
that's not necessary yeah yeah you
wouldn't want to see that plus you've
already had four children like you know
what I mean two twins like I don't
necessarily need to go through it a
third time and put in the memory break
my mom like taking a dump like while I'm
looking at her for JJ you know some
people ask for too much man you got two
twins just just it's good yeah
good you wanted a fifth child yeah maybe
there's something about and wait so
before when they did IVF right was it
the mom every single time no it would it
wasn't in this way I don't know it
doesn't say what they did before so did
they have carrier like just assuming it
was IVF because if they ended up with
two sets of twins usually IVF does have
a probably had a surrogate if the moms
uh was taken out yeah and maybe it
wasn't it was just like a surrogate they
paid for or something which is a lot of
money true and then who knows like maybe
it's like the mom wanted to be pregnant
again I don't know like the thing is I'd
rather keep it in the family like as
weird as it is I'd rather keep it in the
family than introduce a stranger into
the mix and and if the surrogate gets
connected to the baby then that's also
another thing that you're causing trauma
with the surrogate mother but then if
it's within the family the mom has a
connection with your you know and that's
that's great what should be done if you
and Hannah put a baby in your mom
I never even thought about that because
my mom is like 70 something
she's not this healthy yeah but picture
yourself [ __ ] your mom though right
that's a lot better
a lot better dude damn thank God there's
something you can stomach if my mom was
okay like like if who if there if there
was no risks if it was the same
situation if yeah I mean or if it was
her mom or whatever because the love is
up here I think it's fine I think the
only thing I worry about is if the Mom
starts fighting with Hannah about the
connection should be the more mother
role yeah and it's always going to bleed
subconsciously too right if it's yeah
it's like I I did this yeah yeah I I
like really gave birth to this you know
or like you know maybe maybe it's
because we got those Asian moms that no
matter what they're already telling you
every single thing that you did wrong no
matter what but imagine they also gave
birth to your child and then now they
feel untied it's not grandchild because
your mom might be going like okay I'm
gonna drink ginger whatever the first
trimester and then your lady might be
like well actually the studies show like
they should be eating [ __ ] kale
smoothies no no you guys don't know [ __ ]
that mother-in-law war is going to be
heavy it could be having a war the whole
time through well they probably got
those agreements in place and plus you
know we're still working off of the
Asian American Experience second you
said Ginger I was like I already
pictured it you know what I mean I know
there's a lot of anxiety that goes into
having a surrogate because you're always
policing how they're treating their body
yeah you know so it must be it must be
really [ __ ] hard I think yeah it's
more about the relationship more than if
it's if it's feeling gross or not
because the the picture I think is
people flying over oh that's so awkward
and gross you know but I'm more
concerned about like the relationship
within the fact bro this picture
explains all of that just this
she's like that's funniest hey Honestly
though they look like very funny yeah
they look cool man they look cool you
know they don't look like we're in on
the joke of it not like the grandma one
day is gonna be holding her grandchild
and whispering in the ears like
because I've seen that [ __ ] dude where
the [ __ ] grandmas like start robbing
the [ __ ] grandkids and [ __ ] and it's
like let them on mom like you had your
turn which I guess is fine because I
mean they already have four other kids
they've seen my real ones they seem like
some cool ass parents like we got you
yeah I've seen how cool yeah yeah my
aunt was a a surrogate and found out
that um uh later in the pregnancy that
it uh the baby it turned into twins
she like you gotta pay double now yeah I
know right ended up being Twins and then
uh and she gave birth and they still
have a uh she says there still is a
connection like she has a relationship
she still feels like she'll check in
she'll say happy break every year
um yeah she's actually been a nanny a
lot of our life you know she's been a
nanny so she was uh this was also
another like thing as well like
um but uh but yeah she she still has a
connection with the with it so it's also
I get what you're saying too like if
it's in the family then it still stays
in the connection like with the
relationship this might be ignorant but
like uh usually with a surrogate isn't
that already like pretty much like in
Virtual cases right so it's already like
a selected egg a selected sperm in a
sense I mean there's no guarantees but
usually you're already gonna like you
know subtract a lot of possible you know
ailments if you will
um but from there how do you get
surprised that it's twins like how do
you not already know no that all that
but yeah maybe they go it's splitting
time and then they do it later
um yeah like it's like you gotta you got
a baby and as it grows they're like it's
split it has a girl it's like it's
Kirkland time and then they go like that
Mastodon
yeah they're like hey want a twin let's
do it yeah I do know that like with my
high school friends that have had IVF
they they were telling me that like I
don't know if it always works like this
but like they'll take their her egg and
then they'll fertilize it with his sperm
and then it'll like be stored as embryos
yeah yeah to start as embryos okay yeah
so then they they choose whether or not
they want to um which one you want
exactly and then they reach a point
where they go is that it are we done oh
no there's still three other embryos
that are possible to make more kids and
then they decided I think we're good and
then they just go bye-bye yeah which I
think is um technically like
scientifically okay but that's pretty
crazy like when you like know that
that's it's a cool thing to like we're
good with those yeah like that and
they're already embryos well it's also
it's not only it's not only like we're
good with those it's like which one
looks healthiest strongest most
beautiful and like less corrupt kind of
stuff
you're literally looking at which one's
gonna like grow most beautiful you just
see them as like like the the first
episode of Pokemon or you got to pick
yeah
um so we have a lot of friends that went
through IVF and all that and like we
know the details of all the stuff they
have to go through right so Hannah was
like man if that ever comes to be I
don't know if I could do that like I
probably do surrogate before that and I
was like if you want surrogate I know a
great way where we could save money is I
can just pound the hell out of a girl
that's down
and I'll bust in her the natural way not
for like pleasure or anything but for
science yeah and then we can make a baby
that way and then like how do you get
her genetics in it though
that's I don't know
I'm not gonna lie I thought that that's
that's how it went I thought that
circuit yeah you get like a one night
handmaid's tale that [ __ ] somebody has
yeah like uh you have has a baby for us
that's right baby angles look like you
you Mama but like I'm gonna bust a nut
and this girl without sexual pleasure
like uh you know I get the size now but
I mean that's some 1850s
[Music]
thank you